[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it looks
like marble are trying to make Avengers
and game the highest-grossing movie of
all time whatever it takes with the
movie being re-released in cinemas this
weekend I thought I'd break down
everything we know so far to give you a
better understanding of whether it's
worth buying tickets for the film or not
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for click in this video I hope you
enjoyed it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of the New Avengers and game
footage
okay so whilst it was originally
speculated that the new footage would
center around Tony Stark meeting a
teenaged Morgan played by none other
than Catherine Lankford Marvel execs
have come forward and denied this rumor
originally the scene was in screenings
for the film and took place just after
Tony Stark completed the snap that wiped
out Thanos and his forces similar to
Thanos upon carrying out the snap Stark
went to the soulstone and in
conversation with his daughter he was
told that it was worth it however those
who had to provide feedback on the film
in order for it to gets final cut said
that some may find this confusing and
thus it was removed unfortunately it
doesn't look like that scene will be
returning for the theatrical re-release
either with Kevin Feige stating that the
new post-credits scene instead focuses
on smart Hulk whilst we don't have exact
details on this just yet I think I can
make a pretty educated guess on what
this will entail due to what's been said
in interviews by the Russo brothers
apparently the scene is Bruce Banner
focused and now many think this will be
more ancient one dialogue as actually a
big scene that was originally cut from
the film due to the Russo brothers
struggling to think about how it could
fit this scene involves Bruce going
through the transformation process that
turned him into smart Hulk and will
follow his montage in the lab where he
binds the two sides of his personality
together
as one it's a nice little easter egg
that did end up on the cutting room
floor but it's still something that I'm
not exactly that excited to see it was
cut for a reason and I think the
straight editor seems smart Hulk just
sitting in a diner works far better in
addition to this we also know that there
will be a Stan Lee tribute that will
make its way to the blu-ray and then a
three-minute clip of spider-man far from
home which has not been shown in
trailers or promotional material this is
reportedly very similar to the scene at
the end of ant-man which was just a take
from Civil War and honestly it kind of
sounds like a lazy cash-grab to me that
the studio are just putting in place so
they can finally become the
highest-grossing movie of all time
honestly I think it's a kind of ripoff
for fans and was expecting a lot more
from the entire project because if this
is what it is then I don't really think
it's worth returning to the cinema for
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
this reveal and if you'll be going back
to theaters to re-watch the film or if
like me just waiting for the blu-ray and
DVD release I've already seen the film
three times theatrically so yeah I'm not
too pumped for this I don't think it's
gonna add more and if this is their big
ploy to be avatar then they probably
don't deserve it to be honest I will of
course be doing another video later in
the week once we have all of the details
confirmed but now it's it's just very
disappointing reading it comment below
with your thoughts and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full spoiler
breakdown of everything we know about
spider-man far from home which would be
linked at the end we go into full detail
on the film so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you